tout moyen gauche comment vas-tu saint
louis
eh bien voyez madame une gargouille
comme compagnon de visites des géants
qui vous surveille et une guide aux
oreilles pointues pour halloween les
monstres se sont invitées à france
miniature des personnages plus ou moins
effrayant qui déambulent à la rencontre
des passants
ça faisait pas trop perdre au début on
avait un peu peur parce que c'était la
première fois et à la fin ça allait
mieux
j'ai bien aimé j'ai eu un peu peur
j'ai trouvé ça sympa c'est original les
acteurs sont sont marrants et je pense
que les petites ont bien eu peur c'était
sympa la sorcière à cacher des histoires
dans les différentes régions de france
les visiteurs partent donc à la
recherche des contes perdus
sur le chemin ils doivent résoudre des
énigmes pour retrouver les mythes
je suis
rien sans la lumière je suis aussi
l'obscurité
je suis dans chacun de tes pas le petit
chinois jouent avec moi
qui suis-je c'est vraiment une création
originale sur ce parc là est une
création qui permettent aussi aux gens
de découvrir des histoires un peu
inconnu car la france est vrai regorge
vraiment de d'histoires et de légendes
et ses formes est là dessus la quête se
termine à paris la gargouille à trouver
quelque chose
il s'agit de la légende de jean
l'écorcheur assassiné par catherine de
médicis en 15 164 on raconte que son
fantôme serait revenu tourmenter les
nuits de la reine les monstres eu entre
le parc jusqu'à la toussaint